there's an interesting sort of side story
going on with a democratic Congresswoman Tulsi
gabber who is running for the democratic presidential
nomination. She's currently pulling about
1% which is she may actually
lose her congressional reelection campaign
and be removed from Congress altogether in
November of 2020 and a part of what suggests
that is that these races, Mo, most races in
American politics, quite frankly, they depend
heavily on money in the political system that
we have. And while Tulsi is running for president,
she has a challenger in Hawaii who's actually
out fundraising her. The person running against
Tulsi is Hawaii state Senator Kai Kalay, who
has raised more than $345,000 so far. This
is nearly 50% more than Tulsi gabber. It's
221,000 raised during the same time period.
Now, there are a few interesting elements
to this. Number one. Earlier this week, I
already discussed with you that Tulsa Gabard
received a gift over the weekend, which is
that in a campaign that was very clearly winding
down and going nowhere with Tulsa Gabbert,
not even on every debate stage, not qualifying
for the third debate, Hillary Clinton was
accused of suggesting that Tulsi Gabbert is
a Russian asset, although now the original
reports of that by the New York times have
been modified.
In any case, that's a different story. The
credibility of the story. It was a huge boost
to Telsey Gabbert and she is getting more
attention now, but at the same time, she is
up for reelection. Her term in the, uh, United
States Congress representing Hawaii every
two years is up for election and she has an
opponent. Now, there are many States in the
U S where you're not even allowed to run for
president while you are also running for Congress.
Hawaii allows it and Tulsi Gabard can run
simultaneously for reelection in the house
and for the democratic presidential nomination,
but it's not totally clear if she's really
still running for reelection in Hawaii. She's
almost stopped fundraising locally over the
last several months for the congressional
campaign and interestingly her opponent Kaka
Haley has been focusing on how Tulsa has been
distracted by running for president both from
running for reelection, but he makes the case
from her duties as a member of the house of
representatives pointing out that she missed
an important vote on Syria last week, that
she's not spending much time in the district
at all and this is a typical case that is
often made against elected officials who are
going and running for higher office.
Now. There is a ton of speculation that Telsey
doesn't really want to stay in the house of
representatives and that once she drops out
of the presidential race, she may actually
just formally say, I am not going to run for
reelection in the house of representatives.
This is actually a strategy that some politicians
use when they want to leave a position they
run for higher office, that they know they
can't win and then they say, well listen,
I've put my energy into that. I'm not going
to run for reelection or whatever the case
may be. I actually know some people doing
this at the local, uh, local to state level
in a couple of different parts of the country.
I don't know if that's actually tells his
plan. I have no idea now on the merits. Kaka
Haley actually seems like a pretty good choice
to represent Hawaii in Washington D C he supports
Medicare for all period.
Like I don't need to qualify it in any other
way. I don't need to play around with words
like affordability and choice and access and
all this stuff which are often used to not
say I am for Medicare for all period. As far
as Tulsi is concerned, I think she's going
to do just great. I think she can easily line
up a gig a for example, as a Fox news contributor
after she fails to secure the democratic nomination,
I could see her brought onto Fox news as a
contributor that is a Democrat that the right
can feel good about while still calling themselves
fair and balanced but not really stepping
outside of their comfort zone. Sort of like
that guy who on Williams that has been a long
time. Fox news contributor, unclear whether
she'll have to dye her hair blonde before
Fox will hire her, but that remains to be
seen.
She could do lobbying. I mean there's many
possibilities for Tulsa. I think she's going
to do just fine if she loses and then ultimately
withdraws from her Hawaii campaign. Where
do you believe Tulsi Gabard will be a year
from now? Let me know. Uh, if you believe
she will be president of the United States,
well that wouldn't be a year from now. That'd
be a year and a few months. Um, I, I disagree
with you, I can tell you in advance, but uh,
I'm curious to see how many people in the
audience think that she is ripe
for
a
Fox news. Contributorship